.
Thank you.
Good morning for folks that are here for Long Range Capital Planning Utilization Committee.
I'm going to open the 10 o'clock hearing.
I apologize for the delay being 10.08.
And I'm going to, we're waiting for one member more so we can complete our action and have a quorum.
I do apologize.
We will recess for probably 10 minutes when I have that member present.
So thank you for your patience Thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Mark McConkie.
I chair the committee, Long Range Capital Planning and Utilization Committee.
I'd like to return from recess from 1007.
We have one item before us today.
And with that, I would like to turn to the DOT representative to explain to us disposal of highway turnpike funded real estate.
This is item LRCP 23022.
Please, introduce yourself.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Members of the committee, I'm Steve Labonte.
I'm the administrator of the Bureau of Right-of-Way with the New Hampshire Department of Transportation.
We're here today asking for authority to convey a 50-foot wide access easement across three parcels of DOT-owned property, two of which were purchased with highway funds, one of which is rail property.
The reason we're asking for this is that back in the 70s, we had a well-intentioned project.
It was the Franklin Laconia Bypass, which we started acquiring property for at that time.
When we acquired property in this area, we ended up severing access to the parcel owned by JCB, who is the grantee in this case, LLC, we ended up severing access to that parcel back in 1978 when we purchased the property for the corridor for the bypass that I just mentioned.
So when we did that, 20 years passed in the 90s, we still hadn't built the corridor.
JCB's predecessor in interest was still using, was still accessing the property what appears to be over a gravel driveway, which passed over the corridor.
We immortalized that by entering an encroachment agreement with their predecessor and interest.
And what that encroachment agreement said is you can continue to use the gravel driveway.
At some point in the future, what we'll do is we'll grant you a permanent access right to the bypass and if after the bypass if well after the town comes through or party comes through and builds the beach road if DOT prefers they can require that the access be removed be moved to the beach the signalized intersection.
However, that would be on DOT's dime.
And that was basically to make the property owner whole who went through the process of building an access point to the bypass.
So that's why that clause was in here.
So the access point was never built.
The bypass was never built.
The safest way to access the property is by granting them the proposed access easement, which will then bring them to the beach road and the signalized intersection to Route 3, which is why to basically cure this deficiency, we're asking to be able to grant this easement to JCB for no cost, and we're asking the committee to waive the administrative fee.
I'm happy to take any further questions.
Questions for Salamate?
Seeing none.
Chris, if I could, do we believe that we, if a motion were to come forward to accept this, do we need to also make a motion to waive that fee or just a motion?
You could have one motion that accepts the easement as well as waives the fee.
Okay.
Mr.
Chair, then.
Yes, Representative Mills.
Mr.
Chair, I move that we approve LRCP 23022DOT, and further, I move that we request to waive the $1,100 administrative fee.
I'll second that motion.
Thank you.
I'll send Mills motion by Mills, seconded by Couillier.
Any discussion?
Seeing none, if you're in favor of the motion, you signify by saying aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you.
Make a motion to adjourn.
Motion's been made to adjourn.
Seconded by Kluge.
All those in favor, signify by say aye.
Aye.
We are in adjournment until the 15th of the month.
Thank you.